The Bitcoin 2021 Conference in Miami.
Wasn't just a celebration
of the end of the pandemic
and an opportunity to
gather up close and maskless
with more than 10,000
ideological fellow travelers,
it was also a watershed
moment for a technological
and cultural movement
whose goal is nothing short
of the separation of money and state.
Bitcoin emerged just a dozen years ago,
when a pseudonymous genius
shared a nine page paper
on an obscure email list.
And now it's the third largest
currency on the planet.
In another dozen years, we
may look back on Bitcoin 2021
as the Woodstock of the crypto generation.
The headline acts included
former Congressman Ron Paul.
I admit there's a lot of
the things about Bitcoin
and other things that I
don't fully understand,
but I understand liberty
Twitter and Square CEO, Jack Dorsey.
We need to be able to transact
with this every single day
and everyone around the world
needs to transact with it everyday.
Skateboard legend, Tony Hawk,
boxer, Floyd Mayweather,
sex tape, entrepreneur, Paris Hilton,
DJ and record producer Diplo
and Ross Ulbricht who beamed
in from federal prison,
where he is serving an
effective life sentence
for creating the pioneering dark website
"Silk Road" which helped bootstrap
Bitcoin it's early years.
The conference ended with an announcement
that El Salvador will become
the first country on earth
to recognize Bitcoin as legal tender.
I will send to Congress
a bill that will make
Bitcoin a legal tender in El Salvador.
One of the breakout
stars of the conference
was Cynthia Lummis a 66-year
old freshmen Republican Senator
from Wyoming.
From the stage and in an
interview with Reason,
Lummis forcefully made
the case that Bitcoin
not only provides a fully
legitimate alternative
store of value and medium of exchange,
but would act as a
check on the devaluation
of the U.S. dollar and other currencies
through the runaway
creation of fiat money.
She also believes that
the growth of Bitcoin,
assailed for its heavy use of electricity,
is acting as a spur to
create renewable energy
in Wyoming and around the globe.
And she extolled its privacy features
in a world of increasing surveillance
by governments and corporations alike.
Senator, thanks for talking to Reason.
It's my pleasure, Nick.
What's your main interest in crypto?
I mean you're in the Senate
and in Congress more broadly.
You're like a leading light
on this type of stuff.
What do you see as the value
of this new technology?
Especially as it intersects
with a kind of fiat currency system
that has really gone off the rails.
I had been my state's
treasurer, in Wyoming.
I think that suffices,
I understand why you're
interest in crypto.
Yeah, I was always looking
for a store of value
and I see Bitcoin, specifically,
as a great store of value.
Only 21 million will ever be developed.
And so we know that scarcity
will protect its value
going into the future,
unlike the U.S. dollar
that we're printing more
of every single day.
Oh yeah.
I mean, by the end of this interview
there'll be millions more
in circulation, right?
But I would think, you're
in the U.S. Senate,
is Bitcoin or is crypto more broadly,
is that a competitor to the U.S. dollar?
It's not a competitor
but it is an alternative saving instrument
for people like me,
who are concerned that
the U.S. dollar saved,
will be worth far less than
when it's deposited in savings.
So to me, I see it as an
opportunity to save for my future
in something that will grow
in value, not fall in value.
Do you own Bitcoin or other crypto?
I do. I do.
Okay. Are you cashing out?
Oh no.
You're long on Bitcoin.
I'm what they call a Hodler. I'm long.
I'm in it for the distance.
You are a Hodler.
You are working both to bring
kind of an understanding
and a legislative agenda
around crypto into fruition.
What's the regulatory framework
that you want to see crypto
being used that apart from,
currently it basically
is treated as a private
commodity.
Commodity. Mm-hm.
So it's subject to things
like capital gains tax.
Where do you see things going?
What your dream vision?
It is to create a regulatory
and statutory framework.
A sandbox if you will, that
innovators know the parameters
but the parameters don't
constrain them in their innovation
as they develop new uses,
new tools, new opportunities.
So the blockchain will
provide, for example,
the opportunity to put both contracts
and the money or value
associated with that contract
on the blockchain.